hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge mein
kroatisch freitag das heißt ich habe
gedacht ich mache vielleicht mal ne
runde jump league wieder her wir sind
hier und ich hab mir gedacht ja luca die
letzten male minecraft habe ich ja mal
ein bisschen gelabert wenig gezockt hab
über so ein paar themen die ihnen wie
derzeit an anstand
wie soll man das schaffen man über so
ein paar themen die anstanden
so ein bisschen drumrum gequatscht und
halt nicht so wär ja ja ich muss da hoch
und nicht so wirklich aufs gameplay
konzentriert und viele mehr ändern sich
auch luca genutzt ja minecraft nur noch
als unterlage für wenn du irgendwie uns
was sagen willst und soja anfang mai
nutzername gerade ist übrigens stark 62
alles klar digger und viele hatten sich
mal wieder so ein ganz normales gameplay
gewünscht wo ich einfach so ein bisschen
zeige dass mich der skill noch nicht
verlassen ist hier unsere kiste nähe ist
das zum thema skill übrigens alles klar
ein paar wollten halt einfach wieder
dieses school back to the roots mach mal
wieder ganz normal dass du ganz legal
wir wollen die mich dann für komplett
für mich immer wie so ein clown wenn ich
meine videos aufnehmen
aber na ja also ich natürlich hier
wieder kommen jetzt konzentration er ja
okay das geschafft hier wieder rüber ich
wollte heute tatsächlich erst über ein
thema reden was wieder die kanal
änderungen von meinem namen angeht also
ich hab's ja derzeit auf youtube.com
crafter schrägstrich luca ein paar
sekunden später der garnele derzeitiger
name ist kompakter schrecklich luca
meine kanal url ist aber immer noch die
mit konkreter und ich glaube wenn man
auf youtube.com der schluga geht kommt
noch ein zweiter kanal irgendwie report
players of wax post maps eine kiste die
schon fast übersehen
oh mein gott okay das habe ich geschafft
und jetzt
und ihr hoch hüpfen und schwimmen kommen
luca okay so gut und jetzt hier hoch und
jetzt kommt's holiday louis vorletzter
note kaputte mich verarscht wird von
gutmann hierüber alter ist das denn
deren ernst man ey com ich muss dann
wohl so in wie oh mein gott okay okay
jetzt hier rüber und jetzt hier den
seither stehleiter pub ist da in virum
zusprach es war auch viel zur utopie
denken wenn ich das geschafft hätte ein
derzeitiger kanal name ist ja noch
kontrakt um konkrete assoziiert man
immer wieso bin ich da den chef der
summe runter automesse kiste von crafter
verbindet man direkt mit minecraft und
das regt mich ein bisschen auf ich weiß
sie man hat auch irgendwie vor ein zwei
drei tagen sondern video zu dem thema
gemacht dass man nicht sich am kanal
namen orientieren sollte hinsichtlich
das mit zeigten contents wenn ihr
versteht was ich meine
wir müssen wissen mein partner manager
heißt ilja und willi hat mir gerade
geschrieben ganz viel erfolg für die
prüfung an dieser stelle schöne grüße
nicht die prüfung ist tatsächlich schon
drei stunden her aber trotzdem danke
mann und mein gott ich bin auf der
leiter und auch okay okay da ist gut ich
hab noch immer noch vorletzter laurent
schaffter verbindet man irgendwie mit
minecraft um einen kanal besteht derzeit
daraus dass ich pro woche irgendwie
dreiräder videos hochladen und drei
gaming videos und an einem tag vergesse
ich irgendwie mal komplett eine video
hochzuladen bisschen holzschwert besser
oder starts gleich eine 4
ok dann im habe den stein axt bei allem
respekt net die
soll ich das hier schafft es geht nicht
und das regt mich also ein bisschen ob
ich hätte viel lieber als kompletten
simplen kleinen namen einfach nur luca
also ich hab mich mit uk mittlerweile
jonas darüber unterhalten weil er die
gleiche entwicklung gemacht hat und er
auch finde dass ein mann ich komme da
nicht drüber er hat sicher von new dawn
tv überall auf jonas umbenannt und das
ist halt so ganz cool so mut zum risiko
und das finde ich halt selber ganz nah
man solche schritte wagt dann auch
theoretisch jetzt mal diese blöden
parcours mein gott okay ich bin auf dem
nächsten immer noch vorletzter das
einmal wollen die mich dann verkackt
du kannst weg du kannst weg du kannst
auch weg die zieh ich mir an
eisenachs kommt auf die eins sondern
spinne ich überspringe hier wieder hin
springe hier wieder auf das ding darauf
hier auf das ding und 17 uhr läuft sagt
dann hier drauf und jetzt sagt hier
drauf und jade und hier und da ich hätte
wissen müssen dass ich rüber komme
inhalt ganz meisters jonas richter auch
komplett umbenannt hat ich würde das
auch viel lieber haben einfach unter den
namen luca weil ich merke schon so bei
fantreffen ich werde nicht mit konkreter
angesprochen also natürlich auch ein
paar treffen sprechen mich auch mit
konkreter an aber die meisten sprechen
mich an und sagen wir einfach hey luca
und es ist einfach auch viel
persönlicher finde ich so das ist
einfach die cooler man kann der viel
coolere basis zueinander aufbauen und
deswegen bin ich da voll der meinung das
ist
ich werde mich irgendwann meinen kanal
komplett auf luca um männern und das
wollte ich euch nur sagen ich bin
lottozahlen dass ich mir noch vorletzter
bin aber jetzt geht sogar schon los auch
total witzig ich hatte ja eigentlich am
anfang des videos angekündigt dass ich
dass ich nur über das gameplay rede und
jetzt habe ich trotzdem das thema
angeschnitten was ich eigentlich sogar
in meinem google docs table dem kombos
luca den kompass gibt den korbleger
erstes leben verloren alles klar
ja ich wollte mich eigentlich nur auf
das gameplay konzentrieren oder jetzt
bin ich tatsächlich wieder vom thema
abgeschliffen und abpfiff keine ahnung
wie ich und habe trotzdem nur das thema
geredet aber soll egal sein soll ich
konsumiert wie das gameplay und habe
direkt hinter mir wieder ein alles klar
wie kommt sofort ob die komplette map
einfach gegen mich agiert dass ihm ein
schnitzel fallen vielleicht heißt es ja
dann in ruhe
ok erschießt fall war wahrscheinlich hat
den stein schwer
liga alles klar heck doch nein ich habe
keine aggressions probleme
oder doch ich habe ein paar krieg nicht
richtig ganze zeit hinter einer wand und
plötzlich camberg in sein
vorne kommen ja auch leute können bürger
challenge messer auf die beiden spiele
gezahlt oder fünf solo welthit den max
pommer okay das ist das der erste
tatsächlich noch von leben und ich hab
ich hab' ich werde jetzt einfach mal den
bogen benutzen und dann drauf klappen so
dass die sehen dass ich tatsächlich auch
gestorben bin gerade meine fresse an
dieser stelle würde ich auch das video
beenden meine damen und herren das ich
wollte eigentlich zu dem inhalt darauf
legen dass ich wirklich das gameplay
kommentiere eigentlich wollte ich gar
nicht auf dem thema genauer eingehen was
ich dann jedoch trotzdem gemacht habe
tut mir leid wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen aber will ich meine bewertungs
freuen
und was haltet ihr von dass sich
vielleicht demnächst mal wieder so ein
paar mehr minecraft sachen mache wo ich
aber dann einfach wirklich minecraft
kommentiere und nicht über irgendein
thema rede
also schreibt mir das in die kommentare
wir sehen uns das kann ich was
explodiert im game